[Music]
i'm joined now by carl bilt former
foreign minister and prime minister of
sweden
and the very longest a long-standing
watcher of the situation in that part of
the world
so um car belt how delicate is the
situation in ukraine right now if you
look at the sheer number of trips things
look
quite sensitive but i'm not sure if
that's a decoy
well we simply don't know i mean what
what we do know
is that there's been a very significant
build up of military forces on crimea
for some exercises
but also around the borders of ukraine
and the most significant military
buildup since uh
the acute face of the crisis in 2014 and
2015.
these are expensive uh things i mean you
don't do them for fun they are there for
a purpose for some sort of
some sort of thing and and that of
course creates a certain amount of
nervousness
i imagine also that patient will be
testing europe's response now we saw
that after the
incident in salisbury and britain
succeeded in getting europe to give a
combined response
in when we expelled russian diplomats
and but this time around a few days ago
when czech republic and expelled
diplomats
there was not a concerted european
response do you think that european
unity
is beginning to fracture no i don't
think so
i think what has been happening in the
sort of this russia ukraine case
now is that the fact that it has
attracted so much attention and we had x
numbers of telephone calls to put it in
the kremlin
and to president selenski in in key of
offering support i think that has had a
deterrent effect it has been made clear
to president putin that where he could
go
further crossing the obvious red lines
would have significant consequences um
so i think as a matter of fact the
political action of the political
signaling
that we've seen during the last few
weeks have probably
we have to reserve judgment has pro have
probably been successful
right but we've seen recently for
example when joe biden came in
he was keen that germany canceled the
nordstrom 2 projects that would link
expand the pipeline to russia the reason
for that is that poland and indeed the
european parliament were begging germany
not to go ahead with this because this
would allow peach in great far greater
latitude
to get up to more maneuvers in ukraine
germany
is still pressing ahead and
that must be a little bit of a problem
that is a problem primarily i think it's
a problem for the german
american relationship primarily i mean
there's a
as as you're aware of there's
significant opposition in germany also
to this particular pipeline
that being said there is a significant
opposition in
germany to the americans doing sanctions
against an
ally the germans are saying you can have
different views on this one but that is
for us to decide not for you to decide
and try to impose your will so it it's
it is it is uh creating tensions i i
think the
the significance of the issue is
somewhat overblown uh but
uh clearly it's uh it's unfortunate okay
um vladimir putin gave his annual
address to the nation
a few days ago and in it he spoke about
russia as being a tiger surrounded by
hyenas do you think that's how he
regards europe now
as hyenas to his tiger i think he
creates uh
uh yeah i think he has that particular i
mean
my interpretation was as a matter of
fact that sort of the tiger was more
the united states perhaps than the other
hyenas but but anyhow
that's obviously the way he he sees it
but otherwise i was surprised by his
speech
because it was so bland as a matter of
fact
difficult to see that he hadn't thought
of the possibility
of saying something of a relationship
with ukraine but there was
absolutely nothing in it and that sort
of
invites a lot of questions one of the
theories that james forsyth
advanced in the spectator is that putin
might be doing the build-up in ukraine
in order to de-escalate later and take
some credit for it
for example we now get alexander navalny
who's very ill
in a russian prison if something were to
happen to him
then there would be big reactions
certainly from the west
but james is saying in that case putin
might say okay i'm going to de-escalate
ukraine
and then somehow use that to assuage
what would otherwise be a nasty a far
harsher reaction
to the vinovounding situation i doubt
there's any link between the two i think
the these are two different developments
uh
you can perhaps trace them back to the
same common denominator that is that
sort of the nervousness in russia
what's going to happen in september with
the doom elections and the
internal instability tendencies that
there are in the inside the regime
itself
but but otherwise i fail to see any
connection with the between the navalny
crisis
and the and the ukraine crisis we'll see
if they de-escalate i mean there's a
statement coming out of the russian
defense ministry today that they are
sort of starting to withdraw forces well
they've done that from syria or
announced that from syria i don't know
how many times
so we'll have them we just have to wait
and see what happens
how much of this do you think putin is
simply testing new leadership
in the world we've got joe biden we've
got new
new leadership in the european union do
you think he's just prodding to see how
people react
i think it's primarily prodding the the
ukraine leadership i
i i think he's irritated with ukraine
leadership
they have not from his point of view
been delivering the concessions that he
had been hoping for
and they have also lately taken some
rather firm actions against his uh
his close political allies in in in in
ukraine i think that has irritated the
the kremlin quite substantially and i
think the primary signaling here is
uh towards kiev to a certain extent
perhaps uh
against brussels and then and washington
or they think rather that he believes
that
those those relationships are so rock
bottom at the moment
that it doesn't make much of a
difference anyhow what it does
and what kind of signal do you think
mkev is getting
from the from europe in general because
right now if you see
um the miracle government pressing ahead
of nordstrom 2
then you do wonder just um how important
ukraine's protection that ukraine's um
part as part part of europeans near
abroad really is
it might seem as if europe isn't really
much of a position to do anything here
and at all because
putin's successfully playing one country
off against another
well i think it's been a very unified
response there has been telephone calls
from sort of from
chancellor merkel from president macron
for presidency of finland
and and they've all been uh i understand
uh
very clear that if it crosses the red
lines that would be significant uh
significant steps taken by by the
european union
robert can we define significant steps
here i mean anybody can make
phone calls what kind of significant
steps could we plausibly see
the european union take no i i think
that
if if there were to be that open
aggression i mean that's the worst case
analysis
first that would be very close
coordination between brussels and and
and and washington london i would assume
as well
and the measures that can be taking
those would be financial sanctions i
mean the americans took some
some action the other day they were
extremely mild and
and i think one of the reasons the
american sanctions the other day were so
mild was that they send
they want to send the message well we
can do these things
and and we have a lot of room left in
in terms of that and if if if that is
done coordinated across the atlantic it
can have a very significant effect on
the
russian economy and they know that but
putin annexed crimea a few years ago
he's got away with that he's been
effectively wearing waging war in
eastern ukraine for years now with
something like
14 000 dead he's also got away with that
so you can understand why he might think
he might be able to get away with a
little bit more
before there's any serious response from
nato or from the eu or anybody in the
west
but i think the sanctions that have been
decided already there's a lot of
discussion orders have they worked or
have they not worked
um they have not worked in terms of
having him roll back
and sort of give back crimea and give
back to the bus he hasn't done that
but it hasn't gone any further and and
and i think that's a recognition of the
fact that this
these sanctions have had an effect they
have an effect on
sections i mean they're not total trade
sanctions by no means
but they have uh they have a financial
effect on on access to financial markets
they have an effect to
russia's ability to access certain key
high technologies that they need also
for their energy and other
related developments um so i think
there's a
there's an awareness of the fact that
sanctions aren't killing russia
but they're creating quite a lot of
problems
right but i mean domestically vladimir
putin seems to be quite
quite solid right now the protests about
navalny's treatment do seem to be
speaking for a minority of russians
there was one poll showing a third of
russians
think that he wasn't poisoned at all but
further 20 percent
think that navalny was um the victim of
some kind of western plot
so it seems that um domestically
putin's pretty stable well i wouldn't
say pretty stable but but i recently
mistake but i
what what what do you see a significant
divide in russia that is opening up
between what i call the television
generation
i mean the early generation that sort of
are dependent upon what is said on
television
and of course what he said on television
i mean we all fairly aware of
what he said on television in russia but
then you have the junior the jungle
generation that's the internet
generation they don't watch television
um they they access uh
information through youtube which is a
and and this also telegram and
and related cables uh channels in in in
russia
so you see the internet generation being
sort of increasingly sort of critical
by the television generation which is
still bigger
still sort of enthusiasts more
reluctantly
supporting putin
[Music]
you